[Music]
on today's episode we'll be talking
about life after eating disorders
we'll be talking about how to support
your wife when she's struggling with
postpartum
and we're going to be talking about
reconnecting with a grandmother
30 years after an adoption stay tuned
hey good folks i'm john and this is the
dr john deloney show
it's a show where we take your calls
about your life
where i walk alongside you as you are
experiencing relationships
chaos in your life mental health
challenges
parenting figuring out how to be a good
girlfriend or
boyfriend or dealing with people who are
spoiler alert lunatics who are super
fired up because they're
haven't watched the sixth sense which
came out i don't know like 30 years ago
and they're like
what do you mean bruce willis he's dead
what why did you ruin that for me thanks
kelly
or wait what titanic the boat sinks at
the end
great james i don't even know uh spoiler
alert
seriously people watch watch tv shows
right watch tv shows
there is a limit three weeks that's it
three weeks
and after that if you haven't watched it
that's it your fault that's a your
problem right so whatever if you're
looking for honesty
in a world where truth doesn't exist
anymore
or some people still don't know that the
boat sinks at the end of titanic
give me a call i'll give you a first
opinion or a second opinion
and the advice will be pretty much what
you pay for it
worth what you pay for it i'm here to
walk with you so give me a call
1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3290
or email me at askjohn
ramseysolutions.com
let's go straight to the phones we're
going to talk to kimberly
in sacramento california good morning
kimberly how we doing
fine i'm a little nervous but excited
i'm nervous and excited too
so you go first how can i help okay
on christmas day last year my biological
partner grandmother reached out through
ancestry
we've been talking since the first of
the year and my question is how should i
handle for lack of a better word this
new relationship
especially when we meet wow okay so are
you adopted kim
yes so tell me about your how did your
how did your adoption take place how did
it happen um
my birth mom was 19 my
dad was 18. okay
and um
my uh adopted mom's
hairdresser knew the family and she knew
that they couldn't afford another mouth
to feed
and knew that they couldn't handle
another baby in the house
since i have a full brother who's a year
older
oh wow okay so your mom already had a
little baby when you when you were born
yes okay and so was your adopted family
were they wonderful take great care of
you
um for the most part yeah i don't know
sort of
um so have you been in contact with your
birth mom or your birth dad
no um about 2015
i called ancestry to get a quote for
uh for them to find them and it was too
much
okay and surprisingly three days later i
found them on my own
wow okay so y'all have not communicated
though you don't email
or text or anything like that no okay
did you reach out and they reject that
your efforts no um
after finding them on my own um my
pr like i said last year my grandmother
reached out
and we've been talking since okay
so but why haven't you reached out now
that you know who your biological
parents are how come you haven't
contacted them
um
i want them to make the first move
because i don't know what to do or say
hmm and how old are you 30
30 okay so
do you want to talk to them i know we're
gonna get to your grandmother but do you
want to talk to your parents do you want
to meet them
at least once yeah okay so you're i know
that there's the
the parent dynamic and there's the well
they should
you're 30 you're like a a grown woman
all growed up so if you want to reach
him you want to talk to him
shoot him a note okay okay i'm not an
expert in
adoption reconnection and so i'd expect
that to be weird and messy
but it might be beautiful i'm a huge fan
of family restoration i'm a huge fan of
reconciliation
and people saying i'm sorry and people
saying i miss you and i love you
and so i would hate for you to go
through the rest of your life or spend
another year or another week or another
decade
wondering what it would be like to talk
to my birth mother or my birth dad
but just waiting on them okay so that's
my two cents on that one
about your grandmother so do you want to
meet your grandmother y'all
talking about hanging out and having a
drink together tell me what that's going
to be like
okay um she's been really nice
and her husband actually asked her if
she wanted to meet me and she said that
it would totally be up to me about when
and where and or even if
sure so what do you want to do do you
want to yes
i do okay so paint me a picture paint
everybody listening to this paint us a
picture of what this meeting
would be like
okay um it would be
like all of it okay yeah here we go sit
down perfect keep going uh
we've decided to eat at a restaurant
near me okay so it'd be on my home turf
who's paying
we do a small talk maybe and then
who's pay who's paying for the meal
i don't know okay both of us
okay oh split check i like where your
head's at okay so split check i'll take
care of mine
they'll take care of theirs you make
small talk and then what
so hey how's the last i don't know 30
years ben fill me in
um what do you want to accomplish by
meeting your grandmother what do you
want to know
i don't know that's a good question
um what part inside of you and i've got
my hand across my chest here what part
of
you inside wants to meet your
grandmother and why
i've never heard their voice
i want to see what they look like okay
so you're tapping into a magical word
here kim okay
and it's this word of heritage
we all long to know where we're from and
who we're from right
and so the reason i was asking those
questions is not to discourage you in
fact
i'm i'm all for it in the age of the
internet
there is no more hiding there is no more
closed much of anything
and so i'm a huge fan like i said of
families getting back together and
reconciling
the reason i asked you the whys why do
you want to get together what are you
looking for what are you hoping for
is i want to make sure you go into this
with your eyes wide open not expecting a
fantasy and unicorns
and a bunch of toys to you know what i
mean this this
you're not going to get 30 years of your
childhood back right
yeah but when you go into it with this
notion of
i just want to know where i'm from who
i'm from
i want to see who i look like i want to
see if i've got the weird ticks
i want to meet human beings because i
love people
and kimberly i am 1 000 behind you on
this one
i think going into it with your with a
plan
is wise you already have set the bar
really high which i
love i'm high fiving you here from
nashville which you know it's going to
be on your turf you're going to set the
terms and the boundaries
at any moment you're going to get up and
walk out if it gets ridiculous or
uncomfortable or if somebody asks you
for money or anything like that
and if anybody makes you feel guilty or
like why haven't you
take so long to reach out to us and we
just all that kind of nonsense man they
don't get to do that
but hopefully they know that happens and
hopefully it's a lovely get together and
when the waiter
or waitress comes and says who's how do
i do this check and you go first and you
just say
i'll take mine on my tab please and that
will send a message
and hopefully they'll reach out and say
no no we've got it but if they don't
cool great
and what a what an awesome moment this
would be for y'all
so you leave and you go to the the car
after this is over you hug
and you go outside walk me through
your picture of what that's going to
look like
um
i don't know are you gonna get are you
gonna go to your car with a big smile on
your face
are you gonna go to your car and just
put your head on the steering wheel and
cry real hard like
put me in to put me in in your space
what's in your heart and mind here
probably both okay are you really
excited but
in all that it just happened i love it
because here's the deal who knows i you
don't know how it's gonna end i don't
know how it's gonna end
but again i want you to have a picture
in your head of what it's going to
look like that way you're not surprised
that way the night doesn't get weird
that way when they're like well why
don't you just come back to our place
for coffee you say
no i'm going to head home tonight but
let's look to get together again in a
few weeks if it's a great meeting right
if it wasn't a good meeting then
then you then you say other things but
again this here's the idea the one word
i want you to keep in your head
control okay i'm going to add a second
word
boundaries right and so just map those
out
sit down with your husband before you go
y'all map this out
here's where i'm willing to go am i
willing to pay for dinner not willing to
pay for dinner
am i willing to go have coffee or
dessert somewhere else or am i not
am i going to just plan on going home
and what am i going to need when i get
home am i going to need some space
i'm going to need a big hug paint a
picture for for your husband and what
you need him to do for you when you get
home should he be up waiting up for you
with his arms wide open
what's that going to be maybe ask your
grandmother
what what your what your birth mom is up
to would it be wise to reach out to her
you might find some things out that are
positive or negative there so
anyway control and boundaries you're
running the show on this deal but i say
go for it
and be recklessly you and not reckless
and do dumb things and all that
but just be yourself you've got nothing
to prove to anybody
you had a adoptive family that took care
of you you are 30 you're clearly doing
well
and you have value you're awesome and
you don't need the approval
of your your grandmother you don't need
her to
like love you anymore or less you're
just meeting a new person
and if you go into with that attitude
that's going to be incredible and great
i love it
all right let's go to emma in my
hometown
of houston emma good morning how we
doing
i'm doing good how are you doctor john
i'm doing so good hey listen i need you
to help me with a challenge
before we start talking so
man this is frustrating somebody wrote
into the dave ramsey show i coasted the
show the other day and somebody wrote
into the show
and they said i'd like to pose a
challenge to delony
that he get through one stupid episode
of anything
without talking about being from texas
and he said consider the challenge laid
down now here's the challenge here's the
problem as a texan and you know this
number one it's kind of a rule if that's
where you're from you have to
obnoxiously talk about it all the time
because we're so insecure as a state
you have to just mention it to everybody
and the other side of it is you're not
allowed to walk away from a challenge
and so the challenge is to not talk i
feel like i'm going to spontaneously
combust at any moment
so i'm asking you emma what do i do in
this moment do i quit talking about
it or you just say you know what forget
it i'm gonna double down
honestly i double down you can't stop
talking about texas
listen you just can't listen we are a
state
texas is a state that is the most proud
of a battle we lost at the alamo we
didn't win
there was like 11 000 of us first 14.
most people call that insane you know
what texans call that
yeah that's right that's so ridiculous
but anyway
i i should have thought nothing less
than emma saying
ah double down go for it good for you
all right
emma that's not what you called so how
can i help what can i do for you
okay so basically i was
anorexic during my college years and
i've slowly
rounded that corner but i'm still
struggling a lot with the regret and the
shame for the time i wasted
especially now during like these covid
times
because i was already struggling to find
community and this year i was really
motivated to
try new things and meet new people plus
i'm graduating with my master's so i
feel like i should be excited about the
future
but i instead just feel like i wasted
all my young 20 years and because of
these times we're living in
i feel like i don't even have the
opportunity to pursue
like a career and friendships and a
romantic relationship
and i'm usually an optimist but i just
don't know how to find hope in this time
oh i love that question all right so
welcome me back to college how long did
you struggle with
eating disorders
or disordered eating is the right way to
say that yeah
it honestly it probably started like
senior year of high school and then
it was probably a good five or six years
okay
and were you hospitalized was it
something that your friends and family
talked to you about or was it something
that mostly only you and maybe a college
counselor knew about
but that you knew weighed on you're
pretty heavy
um there were times that i probably
should have been hospitalized but it was
just
kind of not something that i talked
about with most people
sort of thing and so when you say
rounding the corner
paint me a picture of what rounding the
corner looks like
um well like i feel like i've kind of
tried to be realistic
about like there just might be some
things that are always
residual in my life that i have to just
fight
on a daily weekly basis okay but for the
most part
like i'm in a healthy enough state
now that like i actually want to
live a better life you know sure
and did you work with somebody were you
with a therapist or a nutritionist or a
group
that walked with you during this journey
not specifically okay you just muscled
it up and powered through yeah
basically so what is a new
control behavior that you have often
when folks
go from you know from anorexia from
bulimia from some of this disorder
eating
from overeating and they really
just grit their teeth and they power
through it
often that behavior gets transferred to
a new controlling behavior
sometimes like another degree sometimes
a new job like a new what's the thing
that you focused on now
that you what's your default go to when
you're struggling when you're lacking
control
when you are feeling a little bit spun
out
um i i don't know
i mean i'm i still like i know that
perfectionistic side of me
is also the piece that like powered the
anorexia
so like i can feel it when i'm like
applying that perfectionism
in like work or school or something like
that and so how do you let the air out
of that perfectionism
how do you get back to a you you don't
fight the urges you can smile
you can talk to people how do you let
the air out of that tire
i don't know i don't know if it's
something like consistent
i think a lot of times i find like i'm
really close to my mom and my sister and
i'll just like call them up and just be
like
just talk through like that moment and
so i guess that's the only like specific
thing i could think of
very cool so i want to challenge you to
do a couple of things
and then we'll talk about the hope and
the optimism okay
okay so the next time well actually
before i do this let me ask you one more
question
in this craziness in this wackadoo world
that we're living in right now
where everything feels unpredictable and
we don't know what tomorrow's going to
look like and we had plans and now the
plans we just
wadded them up and used them for two ply
right are you feeling old urges
re-emerge
or are you kind of done with that
um i i think i'm kind of done with it
i mean there might have been a couple of
moments where like
the fleeting thought is like oh that
would feel so like i would feel so in
control doing that
and then i'm just like no but like the
place i ended up when i went that
direction was like a really really bad
place you know
okay so i need you to hear what you just
said do you realize how far down the
road you are
yeah that's a big big deal
i've met and known and loved folks with
disordered eating challenges
who are unable to years
past where you are unable to wrap their
head around
here's an urge here's a way i can take
control of this moment right now here's
a way i can control
everyone around me but i know where this
leads so i'm not going to do that that's
a
huge victory for you what a gift you've
encouraged me this morning am i just
talking to you on the phone
first you're from houston and now this
that's incredible
um so i want to challenge you to do a
couple of things
one i want you to join some sort of
group
if it's a church group if it is a
a overeaters anonymous group and not
that you're an overeater but just a
disordered eaters
group um whether it's a
professional women's group there in
whatever part of houston you live in i
know there's a number of those groups
there in town
and the reason is is i want you to begin
to practice relationships
and i know that sounds ridiculous
because that's just a thing we all
assume we should be able to do
i have to remind myself to go practice
every once in a while
i had a couple and their kids over to my
house this weekend
and i realized that i'm out of it sounds
so
dumb i'm out of relationship practice i
haven't been having people over because
we we
moved we had covered wheels crazy and
it's just weird it's awkward
and so i'm having to re-experience it
and so what a group is going to give you
is an opportunity to practice
re-learning how to be human again okay
so that's that's the first thing the
second thing is
is tell me what tomorrow you want it to
look like you said you were going to
have a lot of friends you were going to
have
this is going to be the year you're
graduating a master's degree
paint me a picture of what you had in
your head
i don't know i think i just i just
wanted new
like i'd just been stuck in the same
place for so long i just
i don't know i just wanted something new
and fresh and i wanted to like
feel victorious you know okay can i
can i reframe something for you
you spend a part of your 20s in a war
that cannot be won and you came out the
other side of it
you went to battle with the one person
you can't defeat and that's you
and you've come to make peace with who
you are
you've come to relove emma again you
have connected with your mom and your
sister because you're worthy of being
connected to and
now you're on the back end and now
you're walking through the world saying
where can i connect with others
i don't want you to think of your 20s as
something that you wasted
i want that your 20s to be where you
really tilled some hard hard soil
and now you're ready to grow and yeah
dude you launched out and you are ready
to be victorious i want you to tell you
you're a walking victory right now
and i don't know you from the men and
the moon but i can recognize a victory
when i when i hear one
you're a walking victory what you've got
to do now is
you've got to grieve this picture that
we had of 2020 it was going to be this
magic moment
and that we're going to do the roaring
20s all over again and streamers were
going to fall from the sky
like when the rockets won the
championship or when the astros did
before we knew they were all a bunch of
cheaters
and um and you got to grieve that
picture
and then you just got to be about the
business of painting a new one right
what's your master's degree going to be
uh strategic communication
perfect and what do you what did you
what was your vision for what you were
going to do with a strategic
communication degree
um i wanted to do like the whole pr
social media management sort of thing
excellent
which is something you absolutely can do
from the internets absolutely can do in
a wild wackadoo
monstrous city the size of houston and
so i don't think that
i don't think for one stinking second
2020 is over for you
i think the victory is going to look
different you might have to go back to
the starting line and go a different
direction
through a different set of paths in the
woods
but i before you head off i want you
just to exhale
emma and listen to this and if you're
watching this on the youtube i'm making
direct eye contact with you
you are a walking victory people don't
get to the
other side of disordered eating with
their urge
their ability to control urges to
connect urges with
outcomes that's a major step
to then be able to be open and
vulnerable with their mom
and their sister to be able to go to get
a graduate degree
and say i'm going to go help other
people communicate who they are out to
the world
you're a walking victory so i'm proud of
you proud of you proud of you
you've got to get other people in your
life emma now and and
practice relationships and i hope
everyone listening to that i hope you're
driving
practice relationships that sounds
stupid you've got to practice
relationships you're sitting in front of
the youtubes all by yourself
hanging out with just me and be like
practice relationship yes
you and you practice relationships
that's something that we've got to work
on especially in the time of covid right
and the last thing is paint a new
picture
and that's best done with other people
maybe invite your sister over call your
mom do a zoom meeting whatever that
looks like
and paint a new picture of what moving
forward is going to look like
let the picture grieve it let it go of
what 2020 was going to be
and then you're going to find peace
because you're a stud you're an
absolute rock star god almighty emma
it's so good to talk to you
all right i'm gonna take one more call
let's go to calvin in montgomery alabama
calvin what's up brother how can i help
hey john thanks for taking my call and i
uh i speak on behalf of a bunch of
people we really appreciate the dynamic
that you're bringing into the ramsey
group hey thank you so much for for
calling it's a blessing to be here man
how can i help
well in a nutshell um i'm afraid that my
wife is falling into a little bit of a
postpartum depression okay
and i'm really wondering how i as a
husband can walk
with her through this season hmm
so tell me what's going on
um she does have a history of depression
we've been working through this since
really it was
2017 2018. okay
we have we've been blessed with three
beautiful kids um
the first one dates all the way back to
2015 in the summer
um he actually was delivered at 36 weeks
through an emergency c-section
okay um we had some medical issues there
and so that was a very quick
we had to get him out but he's been fine
our second
came a very quick 18 months later um
you kind of chuckled there as though you
don't know how that happened
all right well you know all right so you
have 18 months later then the next kid
right right then the next kid came in
and she was literally born the week
before christmas
okay so this was december 16 we um
bring a new baby home everyone's excited
everyone's down for the holidays
and then here it comes january
everyone's left
i have to go back to work and now here
she is going into
january in february with two little kids
in her lap like okay well now what
right um so lots of exhaustion there
and then it just kind of spiraled
downhill from there over the next couple
years
and then um lots of just
sleeping through the day and other
issues like that
going into 2019 she actually contacted
her ob
that spring and they actually gave her a
like an anxiety medication prescription
which helped um it did help
but then that summer we actually went
and saw a therapist
i went with her for the first one and
she saw continued afterwards for a
couple sessions
we came out of that with a couple tools
in our belt
and we were progressing we made good
headway on it she's remained on vacation
ever since
but she was in a good place now fast
forward to where we are now
we were just blessed with our third
child
um he was born july but when we were in
the hospital we actually had a three-day
nicu stay
okay and that that was just tough
um i've never seen her that emotionally
dark ever before
um through lots of prayer
um and blessings from the lord we're
able to get home
everyone's fine progressing as expected
so definitely a blessing there and about
three weeks ago she's telling me
she's in a good place she's excited
everything's going great
and then seven to ten days ago she
confides in me that we kind of
everything kind of took a left-hand turn
on us um
she can find into me that she's having
weird
dreams one specific one that she told me
was
she dreamed that there was an accident
with the baby and
the anxiety of having to call
like our parents and explain what
happened it literally gave her a minor
panic attack
sure shortness of breath it just was
tough
um i have
since then she also she called back to
her ob and they increased their
medication again to get get through the
season
um i've already pleaded with her to find
a therapist
um i do admit she didn't feel that she
connected very well to the one we saw
back in 2019 so
i'm pleading with her to find someone
that she could connect to
now to talk with and develop some tools
um let me ask you this let me interrupt
you here
so number one thanks for sharing that
that's that that arc of that narrative
is really helpful here
what kind of husband are you man how do
you solve problems
i'm a fixer um if a truck is broke i can
i can find the part i can fix it i can
so you can't you can't see this but all
my notes here i'm holding up
i wrote down problem solver
um and you sound like somebody who loves
their wife
more than life itself and you sound like
somebody who
loves their kids more than life itself
and what you're looking for desperately
is a
set of solutions an instruction manual
on how to fix your wife
because she's hurting and you want to
make that pain go away is that fair
that's absolutely right i and and i
understand that i i can't fix it
i can't there's not a broken bolt
somewhere i can't it's not that easy
that's right brother that's right so
here's a couple things are going to be
really important for you
and for her navigating this this this
sense this water okay
the first thing is this um you can't be
the person who gives her
instructions you can't be the person who
gives her a set of
guidelines or operating rules or new
tools or tasks
okay you're one job on planet earth and
you may have heard me say this over and
over again
and sometimes just hearing it directly
changes so i'm going to keep saying it
keep saying it and keep saying it and
sometimes i'm saying it to myself dude
is your job is not to fix your wife your
job is to be with her
okay she's gonna learn a set of tools
she's gonna work through
this depression and it could be all
kinds of stuff there's a couple things i
wrote down here that
i'll talk to you about but
she needs you on a daily basis when you
wake up every morning
before y'all get out of bed before you
go try to solve the baby's challenges
and i know this is hard i've got a
little kid in my house too
i want you to hold her for two minutes
one full minute three minutes and tell
her some wackadoo
quack on the radio said to do this and
this is important that you get skin on
skin contact
not as something to solve but as a a
person that you love
and that you can be with and then before
you get out of bed
i want you to look her directly in both
of her eyes
and say how can i love you today how was
last night and if she says i had these
really intrusive thoughts i had these
really hard dreams
i want you to say that sucks and i hate
that you're a great mom and i love you
don't say well remember last time and
have you checked in have you made this
call don't do
that she knows to make the calls she
knows that things aren't
super right she just needs somebody to
be with her and to listen okay
and so i want you to replay that three
or four times a day
how can i keep loving you today how can
i love you today and at the end of the
day i want you to hold both of her hands
and look her in the eye and say how did
today go
how was today and most of the time if
somebody's in the throes of
of um of this postpartum
hell it's not going to go great and your
default setting when your wife says i'm
hurting is to think
who is the dude's nose i need to go
break and what you're going to have to
do is look her in the eye and say
that sucks and i hate that i want you to
know that i love you and you're a great
mom
and that's that's that okay so
um and it's gonna be a it's gonna be a
spiritual discipline it's gonna be a
spiritual practice for you
to stop giving advice to stop trying to
fix her and just learn to slowly
be with her okay if she's got a history
of depression so if she had struggled
with depression so i'm backing out a
little bit she struggled with depression
before
kid number one did she have that in her
teenage years or
during college that kind of stuff
not that i'm aware of okay um i was with
her through college but i didn't really
see the tendencies it really didn't
start coming in
okay i'm super prevalent until the 2018
time
so i'm speaking into something that i
can't experience because i'm a guy
but i've read about this and i've heard
it anecdotally from
from important women in my life when you
are raced off to an emergency c-section
there is this notion that my body failed
that my body didn't work the way it was
supposed to women who struggle with
infertility challenges there's this
existential crisis that goes deep into
your core into their core which is
i was put here on earth for one thing
and my body's not doing that one thing
and often guys can't understand the
depth of that trauma how much that
weighs on somebody
and so getting rushed to the hospital
and have to and having to be
saved by doctors by having a baby cut
out of you
there's something that sits in your soul
that says my body is supposed to do one
thing
and it didn't do it and that can really
wreak havoc on folks
the second thing is after um after
emergency c-sections you get all kinds
of
hormonal and and
biological responses that aren't i don't
say aren't normal because c-sections
have become normal but
um it just it's playing whack-a-mole
with hormones and with body chemicals
and stuff
so calling an ob gyn making sure she's
connected with her doctor is critical
and important
and getting connected with a therapist
that's going to help being on meds
forever i don't think that's a great
solution
so you've got to find someone who can
help with hormone reregulation who can
help with diet all those kind of things
and again it goes back to something that
you mentioned that's magic
is finding somebody that you can that
you trust that she feels comfortable
with that she can feel like she can be
in a relationship with
um another thing is this notion of
a woman's body becomes um it becomes a
machine
right when you've got two little kids
and a third one you're just
an exhausted tractor everybody's using
you for a thing right everyone wants you
to accomplish these set of tasks
i got to feed this kid i got to change
this kid i've got to clean this thing
i got to cycle and repeat i'm gonna
sleep two hours i'm gonna get up and
feed
and then you just it again it's an
exhaustion that
many men can't understand because it
gets into your soul
and it's countered with this narrative
that these are supposed to be so lovely
and wonderful and what great times and
right and so you've got this messaging
going in your head these stories that
we're telling ourselves
and it doesn't play out that way in real
life um and then the final thing is this
i can't put my head in the heart of a
woman who's been through
heavy postpartum who struggled with this
whose body didn't work the way
that they had drawn it up the way that
the stories had been told it was going
to work
with a an emergency c-section and all of
a sudden your baby's born baby number
three you've been down this road and
then you've got this emergency nyq stay
that is a that's a recipe for all kinds
of existential challenges
for biological responses stress
responses hormone responses are going to
be flying all over the place so
you're just going to be in a hard hard
place if her doctor's response is well
let's just crank up more meds let's just
crank up more meds let's just crank up
more meds
i want to challenge her i'm going to
challenge you
to get connected to another doctor that
you trust get to neck connected to
a probably a team probably a team of
medical professional a psychological
professional who's going to walk you
through this
and they are going to be the ones that
give her tools they're going to be the
ones that
get feedback from her and support from
her and you're going to be the one who
walks alongside
and is just serves as somebody who is
with her who is holding her arms up when
she's exhausted
who is supporting her and loving her and
your relationship is going to continue
to fuse
closer and closer together you can't fix
her brother
you can be with her and you can love her
and i know for most guys when i just
said that
that is what love is is fixing and if i
can
if i can shake every dude listening to
this out there and let them know your
wife
is not a puzzle to solve and she is not
an engine to fix
she is someone to love and be with let
doctors and
psychologists and counselors be folks
who give new tools
and then you all grow together man hey
listen brother calvin
i'm i'm thinking about you and your wife
she needs to get with the right
professionals
and i'm gonna man i say this over and
over on the show
just an endless we'll just keep up in
the meds that's not a solution long term
that's not a solution long term my
prayer is that your wife will go sit
down with somebody and say i want to
learn to make peace with my body
i want to learn to make peace with my
hormones and i want to learn to make
peace with my own
emotional and physical and psychological
state and so i want someone to
give me some some tools and i want to
practice moving forward
let me know how this goes i want you to
her to find a therapist that works for
her that loves her
and it's probably not going to help for
you to keep beating her on the head with
that one dude
is maybe a recommendation here and there
you
start seeing somebody and let her know
hey i'm going to talk to somebody
because i want to love and support you
the best i can
and maybe she'll follow that lead there
and i hope she's going to get with folks
who can walk alongside her professionals
so
thanks brother for the call as we wrap
up this show
man what a perfect song on the way to
work this morning i was listening to my
friend andrew osenga cd
his latest record called the painted
desert and good folks
you know we we hear about
the beatles and this you know the the
other greatest band of all time poison
we've all got our favorite rappers and
whatnots occasionally you got a buddy
who's like hey i got a new cd out and
you listen to it
um i remember hearing the cd a few years
ago it was at four in the morning and i
was on the way to a trip into the woods
and i almost called him but i was crying
and then i thought ah we're friends i
don't know you that well to call you at
4am and tell you that your record's
making me cry
but on that record the painted desert
record is the single greatest song
ever written in the history of earth
when the earth started spinning people
started singing
and all the songs up until now
fall behind this song it's called the
year of the locust it's track number two
on the painted desert record by andrew
osenga here's the lyrics
we try our hardest not to think about it
who are we fooling we never stop
the longing the hurting the doubting
worn out
from waiting for a parachute drop hey
you
and the reflection of the rear view of a
hit and run at the drive-thru
slow down what you're chasing isn't
something
it's just a screenshot of a rumor in
town
and then the spirit moves upon the water
but listen
take comfort and rest in the heart of an
uncivil war and you're taking a beating
there's blood red on your chest he will
restore the years the locusts have eaten
we're all aching for eden and he will
restore the years the locusts
have eaten andy
this is the dr john dolone show